It has never been easier or a better
time to change your mind because of
how quickly you can grow.  And if you're going to start over
, please don't
call it pivoting.  Hello.  Because that's
obviously not better.  This is Dalton and
Michael and today we're going to talk about whether you
should pivot.  We had never been asked
questions about the
startup pivot before.  So this is
fresh, fresh content.  I would say
this is the most common issue I received
as a YC partner.  Yes.
For someone who wanted to book an
hour of consulting with me, and this
would be the title of the session.
Someone who wasn't someone you couldn't
find.
Yes. If someone said I was
talented, I need to talk to you.
Yes. First interview.
And this would be the topic.  And so I became
very practical doing
these consulting hours.  And I think one of the
great things about these videos is that
we can give you, the audience,
an office-hours experience without
having to meet with everyone.  So I
think we'll start from there, right?
So let me try to ask you
a question as a starting point.  So
, what's the difference in how
you would approach a consulting hour
like this when you're talking to a founder
who's maybe been at it for 3 or 4 months and is
worried about their lack of progress
compared to a founder who's been at it for
2 years? How would you calibrate your approach
slightly differently
based solely on that?  The first thing I did
, my framework for these
kinds of consulting hours, was to
think of myself as a doctor
where, when you go to the office, you don't take
out the prescription pad, at least not a good
doctor.  You don't say, "Well, here's
your recipe."  You know, that would be, I think,
profoundly unethical, I think that would be
the term.    I
came here because of a shoulder problem.  Here
's your shoulder surgery.    It's
been great.  Instead, what I
did was spend a lot of
time at the beginning of the session
asking a lot of questions, just like
a good doctor would when trying to
evaluate you.  They would want to examine you
completely.  They would want to ask about
family history.
There is simply all this context that you need
to make a diagnosis as a doctor
.  And the way I diagnosed
pivot cases would be to ask, okay,
remind me of the story behind the
company.
How long have you been
working on this idea? When did
the founders get together?
How aligned are you, uh,
among the founders, that you're
objectively working on the right idea? How's everything going? Are you all
objectively in agreement about how it's going?
And then I always like to ask, "
What's your next best option?"
So I would say, okay, so they're
asking about changing
direction.  Do you have any ideas
ready or are you simply adrift
in a blue ocean
of uncertainty?  Uh, because again
at that point, let's suppose they
said, "Oh, Dalton, yes, we do have other
ideas."  I mean, well, what are they
? What are your top three?
Yes.
Because sometimes his
number one backup idea was phenomenally good.
Yes.
And they dedicated a lot of time and
thought to it.
And then my diagnosis would be something like:
"Well, it sounds, it seems like they have a lot of
conviction in that idea and they've
thought about it a lot. Maybe they should
consider that."  Versus: "Oh, we don't
have any other ideas. We're just
asking you this very abstract question."
Mhm.
I would tend to be like, well,
so I'll pause here.  And the
way I think about this is that there's kind of
a decision tree when you
ask a lot of questions, uh,
about the founders' context,
and, like you said a moment ago,
Michael, if it's a company that's
been in the group for four weeks and
hasn't spoken to a single customer and doesn't
have any other ideas, I would generally
say yes, they probably
shouldn't change direction.
At least they should try.
But if they've been working on it
for three years and it's not getting
anywhere, then yes, they should probably
change, right?  On average,
founders know less about the
problem they are trying to solve than they
think.  And there is this framework of: "I am going
to start this company because I know
the right solution," which is a
useful framework for convincing yourself to
start a company.  But the reality,
in my opinion, is that in the early
years of a company, you
're really trying to figure everything out,
trying to understand what the
customer's problem is.  Can it be
resolved? Is it worth resolving everything
?  And what I find is that I
encounter, and this is very, very
widespread, two types of
founders.  I encounter a type of
founder who, once he realizes
that his worldview is
slightly different, uh, from what the
world is turning out to be.  They get scared
and think that it's a more
difficult problem than they believed, but that the
other one is easier.  They want to escape from what is
difficult.  And that's what I usually see
as an early change.
100%.  Let me give you a
textbook example.  And yes, I say this with great
affection, audience.  If anyone is
working on this, I don't want them to
take it the wrong way, but the classic scenario was
companies working on some idea.
They say, "Okay, let's change
course."
We are thinking about dentists.  For
some reason, the dentist thing
seemed very...Yes.  Like something to
fill out forms for you.
Yes. This sounds difficult, but I
asked ChatGPT
and I think we'll go to the dentists, and
I'm thinking, "Oh, another one of these."  That was
the classic exchange.
I thought you were going to go into the
user interview part.  That was another
classic.
And again, I'm sure there are
great dentistry startups out there.  We
love them.  Without meaning to belittle.  Except...
That was a great example of a
startup idea that seems easy for some
reason.  Many founders are looking for an
easier startup idea.
Yes.
They are attracted to dentistry.
And I always find it entertaining.  So
continue.
And then there was the second type of
conversation about changes that I had,
where the founder already knows his
industry.  They really know their
customer.  I can sit down and have a
very interesting half-hour conversation
about what they have learned
and they can teach me many things.  And
when that founder says he
wants to change, I take it in a
completely different way.  Basically,
I'm wondering if they've tested their
main hypothesis and if it hasn't
worked.  And once that happens and they've
put in a genuine effort, they
should basically change or close down
.  I think...
I think it's fair.  Another guideline I
applied in my diagnosis if it was a
developer tool: I
would say, well, are you
using it?
Yes. Oh God, that's very important.  And it
was surprising how many companies that
created
developer tools didn't bother to
use their own product.  That was
the whole thesis on pivoting or making a
tool for developers.  In other
words, if you're a developer,
this is what you know well.
We spent six months building this
AI programming thing or whatever it
is.  And I said, well, great.  Are they
using it daily?  And they tell me,
no, we're using... You
know, we'll get back to you about that.
That was usually a sign that it
probably wasn't the
right space for them, or at least they were
n't on the right track.  So let's
say everything we've talked about before
.  I believe in the pre-AI world and
the post-AI world.  Let's talk about how the
world of AI is changing this concept of
pivoting.  One of the things I see is
that many of the hypotheses that the
founders had about how
the world works for companies that started,
let's say, before February of this year,
that was my awakening.  Maybe it was
like December, but December, the
code in the cloud.  Yes. Yes. Perhaps
AI is proving that some of
those hypotheses are wrong.
So let's talk about a company where
basically its set of
assumptions is: Oh, it takes 100
developers to build X, or it
takes a lot of humans to do Y,
or the best thing we can do to
improve a process is to improve the
interface and some screens and
workflows.  What do we think about
pivoting in those companies where perhaps
the central assumption is now
simply incorrect?
Yes. And maybe they don't have to have been around for two
years; they're coming out to clients
now, and their core customers are categorically saying that
this is not what's
happening.  But maybe they've
raised money and are excited,
what are your thoughts on that kind of case?
This is a very nuanced opinion, and I'm
glad I have video to do this
because I don't know how I would tweet this.
This is a very subtle point.  So
this is what I would say.  There has never
been an easier or better time
to change your idea because of how
quickly you can grow and the
growth rates are real.  And then you
're assuming a
higher opportunity cost than ever before by continuing to
work on an idea that has been
structurally rendered obsolete by
cloud-based code or whatever,
right?  It's super clear.  Can I
elaborate on that?  I would also argue
that AI probably opens up a wider range
of opportunities.  So, there
were probably more opportunities
post-AI than pre-AI.
But the nuance here
is that I would be very sad if
people were watching this video
and it led them to a
pivot hell.
Yes. No, no.
And let me define
pivot hell.  It's where you change your mind every
week.
Yes.
And you just scroll through whatever you
read on social media and you
have no conviction.  You're just chasing
fashion and you're like, "
Yes." It's like you lack conviction.
You have no ideas.  You are merely a vessel
for what you read on X.com.
Yes.
And
what money he just raised.    It
would be very sad if someone saw this
video and accidentally dragged them into
the hell of course changes.
So the nuance here is that it's a
very fine line.  It's
such a delicate balance for the viewer, the yes
, you know, it's not working.
You should probably roll the
dice again.  It's like you're making an
attempt in the age of AI, and if you're going to
launch,
please don't go into the hell of course-changing
.  Like, that's
obviously not better.  And
again, there are some comments
I would give, or a structure I would
give someone when choosing ideas, which
is to try to find an idea that
you know something about.  Try to find an
idea that can help you get
early customers.  Try to come up with
an idea that isn't just a
repetition of who's raising a
lot of money.  Try to avoid the obvious, you
know, gravitational pull
towards the hell of
course changes, which again is a very
bad place to be.  It's better.  Honestly, it
's better to work on a not-so-
good idea than in the hell of change
, which is very complex.  Again, what we
're saying is
yes, very complex.  I think if
we could
randomly pick many
early-stage founders, it would never be
attributed to them.  I think a
common belief is that most
winning companies were founded by people who
just played around in the arena and
discovered something.  And this whole idea of
knowing something about what you work on is not
true.  The stories are more like: "
This seemed cool and I tried it, I did
a bunch of experiments and this
ended up working," rather than: "I
really had some kind of
deep connection with this space of
ideas."  And I think what frustrates me is
that when I look at the winners,
I can always make a connection, or much more
often than not, I can make a
deep connection with what the
founder was interested in.  And you know, I think
we experienced this personally on
Twitch, and it was strange to see, because I
think there was an initial phase where
we were trying to create celebrities.
And Justin was the first and he wanted to be
a celebrity, so we were
solving his problem.  Then there was a
sort of intermediate phase where
we only cared about the graphs, the
metrics, and whether more people were coming to the
website, and then came the phase that
worked, which was more or less Emmett
becoming interested in video games, and
he's interested in them in a somewhat
irrational way.
Yes. And it's really interesting when I review
so many startup stories and get to the
bottom of things, like, why are
you doing this?  And then something like this comes out:
"Oh, my dad was a pharmacist" or "
I grew up in a restaurant".  You know, there was
something real there, and I always think
: if you're competing against someone who's
just following the
random path of what sounds like a good
idea and they're doing something that
...
If they're doing their life's work
and you're just hanging around,
trying to get lucky,
who's going to win?
Yes. So it doesn't seem counterintuitive to
say this, but your best chance
is in a game you know how to play.  Your
best bet, even if it seems
outdated, is probably something you
already knew before you sat down
to think about startup ideas.  And I don't
think people like to hear
that because they say, "I grew up in a
middle-class family, went to a good
school, and didn't have any problems."  How do
you advise someone on what to do
next if you
're convinced that
what's working isn't working?
There are two things I would do.  First,
my diagnosis would be to understand if their
natural state is to pivot too much or
too little.  Do
you have a case of "pivotitis"?
Yes.
Or do you have a case of...
Yes. I don't have a name for that.  Alright
.  The opposite.  The opposite.  And if
someone were already pivoting every
week, I would prescribe: don't pivot for
3 months.  Force yourselves to work on this long
enough to learn something,
because right now you're getting
such superficial ideas by working on
one idea for only a week and then
switching back again.  You're not learning
anything.  You're wasting your time if
you change every week.  So, my
recipe is: work, choose any
idea.  I don't care which one it is, but
force yourself to work on it for
three months.  And...
so that you have enough time to
learn something.
What about the opposite?  Well, the
opposite would be that they've been
working on something for two years and it
still doesn't work at all.  So I would
tell them:
do something like it's a recipe:
just try several things,
because your natural tendency is to never
try anything new.  And that advice
is always much harder for an
advanced technology company where,
if the founders are doctors or something
similar,
there are only a limited number of ideas they
can actually work on.    That's why it
's more complicated;
the scope of things they could
try is much smaller.  Okay,
let's wrap this up with a couple of
interesting ideas, and I'll
desperately try not to make them
depressing, but here goes.  One
observation that I think we both
share is that there were a large number
of mobile startups funded before
the iPhone App Store.  There were
people developing for Blackberry,
for basic phones, for Palm OS,
for Microsoft.  These were all
smartphone platforms
before iOS, and from what I can see, none
of the big mobile winners
started until after
the new platform was adopted.  So
what's going on there, right?  Because I think
if I'm a basic-principles thinker
, I'd say, "Here's a
company that already understands the power of
smartphones, that already has
live software on them, that has
funding and good engineers, wouldn't they
have a much bigger advantage?"  Yes. In
front of someone starting from scratch
now that they have an iPhone in their hand
saying, "Oh, this is what I'd
like them to do."  I think if I
wanted to analyze that thought, it's that it's
a disadvantage to have the inertia
of working on the wrong thing, and if
you spent a lot of time and effort
porting your mobile game to BlackBerry and
the iPhone comes out,
you're going to have many excuses not to
basically restart your entire company.
Like, on the day the iPhone comes out,
you say: "Okay, let's fire
everyone, throw away all the code that
took us years to build, and
admit to our investors
that we were wrong."  And I think there are
probably some founders
who have the ability to do that.
But most people don't.  I think what you're getting at
is that it's
something that's happened with AI, where
many companies that have been around for
a while
need to say, "Well,
let's just reboot everything."
You know, like saying, "All that stuff
we spent millions of dollars on, all that
code we wrote, is worthless and
could be replicated in two months with
code in the cloud."  Thank you for
participating.  And basically, you have to
declare something like an
emotional bankruptcy of your current business in order to
truly restart it.
Yes.
It's very difficult to do,
unlike a new company, where there are
no emotions.  They say, "Great,
we started yesterday."  Yes.
So it's almost as if an
existing company has to catch up
with a new company.  They have to
go through the emotional state of letting
go of all that and detaching themselves from all the
previous costs.
Most people can't, don't
want to, or choose not to do that, right?
What I hope is that this cycle will be
different.  And this is what I've seen.
I have a couple of companies in mind.  One
thing I've noticed is that many more
companies, which reached
advanced stages before AI, had
founders take in some
secondary liquidity.  And, in a strange way,
that's useful.  In a curious way
, it gives them the freedom to say: "I can
bet more because, if this doesn't
work, at least I've already obtained some
secondary liquidity."  So, I'm
looking into that.  And secondly, I think that many
founders, perhaps because of some of
our advice, I don't know, when they
went through COVID and saw
crazy times, became more
financially responsible.
Yes.
So it's much easier to think
about these big changes when you're running
your business with a break-even point,
as opposed to having this train and not being
able to keep up with the lie.
If you think, "Oh no, the board is going to
fire me."  If you feel like the sword of
Damocles is hanging over your head, it
's more difficult.
It's much harder to say, "Hey,
everything we did is worthless."  That
's a much harder selling point
.
Yes. More difficult to explain to your
board.
So I've seen a couple of companies in
this situation
actually reboot, and the funny thing about it
is that, in a way, if they
can embrace this, it's an advantage.
They have a high level of ambition and
are really good at what they do.
They've brought this business this far, so
they're actually quite talented.
Often, if they are powered by AI,
they can look at everything they've done before
and see, "Oh, we could have done it
this way," and they can package that up and
use it.
Yes.
And they often had time to
learn about some customers,
some markets, some problems.
We have some prospects, so I
hope and, well, I'm optimistic that
this cycle is different.  But I think
if I were the founder of a company
with, say, $10 million to $300
million in revenue, and most of
the business was built on
pre-AI assumptions.  This is a
decisive moment, isn't it?  In five
years, you'll look back on this
moment and ask yourself some very
difficult questions.  I would say that, for example,
if you're a company with $500 million to $1 billion
in revenue and a good economy,
and maybe you can go public in the
next year or two, you might be able to
overcome the barrier, but if you're not
there, that barrier is moving.  And
sometimes I talk to founders and I
just tell them, "Look, you have to
make a bigger movement than
you think."  Yes.
And it's so difficult,
and it's almost as if they know it.    They
simply feel unable to
make the move.  They say, "Yes, I
know."  "I know".  "But" "
But then"
Yes. Yes. If they were advising
another company, they would tell them to make
the move.  Yes.
And it's difficult.  But I will tell you that
people are doing it.  There are people
starting products with zero income.
Yes. They
have tens of millions in
revenue.  And as you mentioned
before, AI is a
powerful tool.  You can grow fast.    Of course
.
You can, if you have the right idea,
you can make moves.  And that's why
I think more companies, in 5
years, will look back on this
moment and say:
Why didn't we do X?
Was this the iPhone's moment?
Yes.
Should we have bet everything?  And the
good thing about many of these companies, and
perhaps it was different in the
mobile world, is that many of them have money.
Yes. Capital is not the problem.  And I
think I also hear a lot of the
story of "what will my
investors think?", and it's like you're
the investor now.
Can?
Your job is not to manage
appearances.
Unless it's someone who can
fire you, and again, we don't
take seats on the board of directors,
so at Standard Capital...
Structurally, there's no universe where
you have to worry about Dalton
being upset with you, you're fine.
But your job is to win.
and that they yield returns as an investment, not that they
yield returns for us, as if it were
for my entertainment.  It's like saying:
I hope this investment works out and
I want to help you as best I can,
but at the end of the day, that's what
matters.  And I think that, sometimes,
founders believe that the
personal relationship matters more than whether their
company is doing well.  And I, as a
former founder, just like you, know that's
not true.
No, no, no.
What matters most is that the company
works.  Well, the funny thing is that
you didn't mention whether the first
idea works or whether what the company is
doing now works.
None of that matters.
Only the company.  If the company is
successful, the investor will boast about it
.
Yes.
Will he?
Amen.    They will do it
, you may not even know they
invested.
It's true.    There
are no extra points for saying, "it was my
first idea."  No extra points.
No extra points.  I suppose that's my
final thought for
early-stage founders.  Yes.
That's something I would always give to people; there's
an old video where I talk about
pivoting.  It's still on the
YC channel.  I think it's called "all about
pivoting."
And one of my comments is:
the best course corrections come from
the founder's area of ​​expertise.
Yes.
A good change of direction feels like
coming home.  Yes. So what I would
say is that if you're on the
precipice of pivoting,
you should ask yourself: What makes me
special? What am I the best in the
world at?  And sometimes you don't know it.  Something
I did a lot as a partner at YC was
tell the founder what made him
special.  I was looking at his LinkedIn profile.  I would review
his resume and say to him, "Wow,
you used to write articles on this
very esoteric topic when you were a student."
What do you think?  And they would say, "Oh, I
never thought of that, Dalton. I was
too busy worrying about
dentists."
And I would say to them, "Well, it seems you
know a lot about what you
were writing about."
And how much do you really know about
dentists?
Exact.  Oh really.  And sometimes, when you
're in your own little world,
you forget
what makes you special, different, and
what you're a world expert at.  So I
really encourage the audience,
yes,
to take stock
of
their upbringing, where they come from, the
jobs they've had, even their
internships.
And maybe you have more
elite experience than you think.  And that is a
great source to move towards, not to move
away from.  I love that idea
because most founders
will say that none of that is trendy
now and it's like, yeah, we're aiming for it to
look good in 10 years.  Yes. Uh-huh.  We are not
worried about today.
Yes. Yes.
So if you're not an expert in
AI or machine learning today, that's
okay.  I would only speak for myself as an
advisor.  It's much more fun to
work with a founder who has
experience in what they're doing.    It's
much more rewarding.  I do
n't think people think about this, but as an
advisor, when the founder can
teach you something, it gives you more energy
to help him.
As a founder, when you feel you know
more about the problem they're
solving than they do, it's
a nuisance.
Yeah. Unless it's your
weird hobby or something, but it's like...
wow, I really wish people
would start with their own experience instead
of starting with what's trendy.    That
would be great.  Okay, good
luck pivoting or not pivoting.
Thank you, Michael.  I apreciate it.